hello steve kaufman here today i'm going
to talk about russian my experience with
russian
about how i learned the language
some comments about the language
and i'm going to begin by explaining a
bit about russia and russian culture as
i perceive it i had mentioned in my
video about
learning french that the french like to
be very logical at least that's what
they teach at school and they'd like to
be very precise and how they you know
explain themselves and so forth
the japanese is
not at all that way and also there's a
lot of understatement in japanese
uh they don't say no they say you know
we're gonna certainly consider your
suggestion which means no
uh the russians are not like that the
russians say no
if it's no they say no
uh they also
very much like uh i mean all people
generalize but in russia there's no
political correctness there is just
generalizations
they say anything
as they say in russian they'll say
anything based on knowing the subject
not knowing the subject getting the
facts wrong
i hear this all the time on ekkomuskvi
the most amazing statements
with but with tremendous drama and
conviction
and so i'm gonna do the same i'm gonna
make
very generalized statements about russia
and russians without worrying too much
about my facts
so
uh how did i get started well i was uh
about 60 and uh i had really two reasons
for getting into russian
one was that i had read you know books
by dostoyevsky and tolstoy when i was 17
18 and
i thought it'd be really cool to be able
to read those books in the original
and the second thing was that you know
my approach to language learning is to
de-emphasize grammar not to ignore
grammar but to not put it up front
and to focus on
exposing myself to the language through
lots of listening and reading
and and emphasizing really you know
noticing patterns rather than
complicated grammar rules uh
explanations and so forth and i was sort
of challenged and said well you can't do
that with russian because the
uh the grammar is too complicated
okay the grammar is very complicated
russian is a difficult language
uh and uh to some extent some people say
no language is more difficult
blah blah blah in fact some languages
are more difficult than others it all
depends on the language that you're
starting from of course but for people
without any background in slavic
languages russian is difficult and i'm
going to explain why
but before that i'll talk a little bit
about russia
russia is
is a phenomenal country i mean the scale
the size of russia is mind-boggling
and if we go back in history we'll see
that um you know
whatever it was that duchess dutch
dukedom or whatever it was muscovy
was this little uh area up in northern
russia uh where
people of i guess a mixture of slavic
and
you know finnish type people and baltic
type people and so forth they were
up there doing their thing i can't
remember whether they were actually
conquered by the um
by the mongol hordes who dominated you
know the mongol tartar hordes that
dominated russia
for 300 years i think they were i can't
remember but whatever it was the prince
up there eventually defeated them and so
so really the growth of russia even
though there were
people in in the sort of area of what's
now the ukraine that were also russians
and kiev is called the mother of all
russian cities and so forth but they
were
very much under the rule of the mongols
for 300 years
and uh
so this this muscovy was up there and
you know interacting with baltic
countries and germans and swedes and
stuff like that and not very different
perhaps other than that they spoke a
different language but culturally very
much in that sphere and from that it
expanded to the pacific
uh you know from the moment they
defeated the mongols
uh within a few hundred years they had
expanded south
right down to the caspian sea that
expanded you know i think they reached
the pacific in the late 1600s and they
only overthrew the mongol yoke as it's
called
in the late or in the mid 1500s again my
history is far you read it you forget it
but roughly so it has become this this
tremendous continental country
and so you're very much aware of this
and of course subsequent to that under
catherine the great and other czars they
consolidated their hold on these
central asian areas and caucuses you
know and they there's a significant
expansion in the 19th century
south and
east
i mean
cyrus russia was very much an
imperialist power
an imperialist power on somewhat weak
legs because they expanded too quickly
and they were defeated by the japanese
in 1905 and from that the whole
uh you know
largely because of the first world war
the tsarist empire collapsed and they
had their revolution and became the
soviet union but all of that is still
very international with people from
central asia turkic type people
the caucasus with all of their different
languages and cultures some islamic some
very early christian and so forth
and of course they were always meddling
in on the western side of their border
since you know participating in the
partition of poland and uh chipping away
at romania and and uh of course
so it's it's kind of been involved in
all these different areas so it's
absolutely fascinating
and uh so that's one of the things you
sense with russia that the scale is just
is just huge
and uh now even now if i listen to uh
echo muskego
you know there are a lot of people there
with with georgian names that are no
longer georgian so even with the
disintegration of the soviet empire
uh you're aware of these influences and
now have a problem with
problem or whatever there are issues
with all the different minorities within
russia plus immigration from countries
in the former uh soviet union and stuff
so that that's the world it's a very
much a eurasian world
and we have to understand that they're
not just like some
european country that speaks islamic
language
all right that's my way of background
the language
uh
yeah it starts out with drastic that's
like hello so in english we say hello
it's pretty easy to say
uh
okay there's not a lot of vowels in
there
uh and all they're saying is hello you
know you practice that in front of the
mirror a few times you got to clear the
you know the expectoration off the
mirror
uh just joking by the way shukkah as
they say in russia uh you know and uh of
course czech has even fewer vowels
so i kind of think the slavs wherever
they started from somewhere in in uh
on the plains of the eurasian steps
there they must have spent a lot of
their time chewing sunflower seeds and
spitting them out
to arrive with a language that uh has so
few vowels and so many things that you
sort of say through your
teeth and and lips and just joking by
the way so but it's an indication that
the pronunciation is not easy and there
are a few little things that are kind of
deceptive like
the o
if it's not
stressed in a word becomes a
so toronto is taranta
you know because the o becomes an uh so
that makes the spelling a little bit
difficult so there are some issues with
pronunciation you know getting your
tongue and lips around all these
consonants
and getting used to how the
writing system works
on the subject of the writing system
you know compared to learning chinese
it's easy
but in a way it's not easy because it's
very similar i mean it's a it's a
almost parallel alphabet to the latin
alphabet which is not surprising because
it comes from the greek alphabet and so
does the latin alphabet which in turn
comes from the phoenician alphabet
uh but there are some letters that are
unique to uh russian the jour and then
they have two characters that both are
pronounced sure i can't tell the
difference and i don't really know and
i've never worried about it and they
have a little b-flat sign which is
supposed to soften the sounds and stuff
so there's a few little things in there
that you have to get used to
uh
but there are some some letters that
look like latin letters and they in fact
they're pronounced differently like what
looks like a p is actually an r and
since
it's very much hardwired in our minds
that that's a p it takes a while to get
over that it takes a while but it
eventually happens so the only
advice on the alphabet is to get started
on it you're going to be able to start
reading with difficulty within a few
hours and then the more you read the
better you get at it however as i found
when i went to check
it's always easier to read in your own
alphabet always so that is always going
to be a bit of a
a thing that makes russian just that
little bit more difficult
the other thing that's difficult in
russian
i i'm not going to go through all the
different you know how the language
works obviously word order is an issue
word order in russian is very flexible
uh and very different in some ways you
know you can say um
you know uh what could be okay this is
this is a book in english the russians
don't worry about articles
this book
to ask you know
if you say i read
a book the book
but you can also say
so that the word order can kind of be
shifted around and that's possible
because oh i should add to a lot of
their questions you only can tell it's a
question by the intonation
if you
uh they don't want to get into the
french keska say or okay okay in
portuguese it's just uber
you have
which is kind of easy
but they can shift the words around in
the order because of the case system and
now i'm going to spend a little time on
the three big bug bears in russian the
three major problems that you have to
overcome
the cases
the second one is verbs of motion and
the third one is the aspect of verbs
everything else kind of you can get used
to but those three i'm still struggling
with
so this video i can see is going to be a
little bit longer than the others but
nevertheless i hope it's worthwhile
cases some people don't know what cases
are
i had latin at school
we had to decline you know
bellum as fast as possible
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
those are the
singular and plural
six cases of the rat latin noun bellum
meaning war belomer however it's
pronounced
in russian there are six cases not the
same
latin has the vocative which the
russians don't have although the czechs
do
the cases the concept is quite
straightforward in other words
if
a noun is the subject of a sentence
i go the book is on the table then it's
in the nominativ
if you do something
to the book i give the book to you i
give the book now the book is in the
accusative because you've done something
to it
if i give the book to you i'd be giving
it to you dative to donation give that's
the dative
then they have a thing called the
prepositional case
which is basically where something is on
the at the in the sort of like a
location location type case in that case
the noun will have a different ending
and then they have
what i forgot the genitive which means
to belong to something
so of the book
of the book would be in the genitive and
they have a thing called the
instrumental
by the book you know um
buy
my pen or
anything that implies what instrument
what was the agent that you use to do
something in that case i went by car
then the car will be in the instrumental
so those are the cases there are six
cases
the endings for example u might be the
accusative for the feminine it might be
the dative for the masculine and neuter
so the endings kind of shift around
which doesn't help
uh
and of course you have masculine
neuter and feminine so you got all kinds
of different endings that you have to
learn
that starts to become a problem
the problem with the cases is that that
in as a general overview the concept is
not difficult
but the specific you know explanations
of why we use one case or another are
extremely confusing and if i were to
read you from this book here
uh picked out you know in for every case
there are like
a variety you know here's okay the
genitive case is used afterwards
expressing expressing measure and
quantity that's fine but if it's one of
something it's the nominative singular
if it's two three or four of something
it's the genitive singular if it's five
or more it's the genitive plural now if
that was the only rule you had to learn
you could probably deal with it
but there's lots more you know the
genitive case is used in a positive
sense to express an indefinite
incomplete and indefinite incomplete
quantity
okay
good for you and you go on iran you know
if you go on to the uh
the uh accusative
you know it's the genitive case is
normally used after negated verbs in the
following instances when the negation is
intensified by another word when a
partitive sentence is negated all the
stuff i mean
of course i don't know what that means
but i have to look at the examples
uh you know some what are we you know
the dative is usually expressed the
logical subject i mean it just goes on
and on a b c d f g
uh
whatever h
and you know like the vast majority of
prepositions don't take the
prepositional case they take the
genitive case and the same preposition
will sometimes take the genitive and
sometimes takes the take the accusative
uh and so it just it's extremely
difficult and the endings the tables
have looked at those tables so many
times
and you can kind of half remember it for
a day or two and then it's gone
and even if you understand the
explanations after lots of examples and
i should say that that this grammar book
with all of its explanations i always
use as an example of how
horrible grammar explanations can be
i have another book that i bought in
moscow which just has examples and if
with enough examples you can start to
see it
however what i found is
ultimately you just have to read and
listen so often that certain phrases
start to sound natural with their
endings
it was much like learning tones in
chinese trying to remember the
individual tone for each
character was very difficult but with
enough
practice you eventually get better and
better okay and i'll just digress a bit
i am a big proponent of lots of
listening and reading but to get good
eventually you have to do a lot of
speaking i have done a lot of speaking
in japanese in french even in chinese
because i used to go to china you know a
month a year when i was in hong kong
attending the hong kong or the canton
trade fair speaking chinese all the time
i've spoken a lot of chinese i haven't
spoken a lot of russian so i speak
still with a lot of
hesitation and and mistakes eventually
you got to speak a lot but you have to
also continue listening and reading so
cases that's number one you're always in
my view going to have trouble with the
cases perhaps someone who attends a
class is studying it formally maybe does
better than i did i was spending an hour
a day most of it in my car while
exercising listening uh it was you know
it's it's an interest thing it's not i'm
not passing a test
however i must say that uh given that i
spent five years at it an hour a day
ah a lot of people
study it very seriously in class and
that don't get as far along as i did
and besides which i can understand so
much
and this is another thing
when you don't understand or you don't
know the cases it doesn't prevent you
from understanding if you have the words
some things remain a little bit fuzzy
but it's sufficiently redundant
the whole context is that you can still
understand learn words on link where i
learned all my words and enjoy the
language learn about the country the
culture
uh
and and even though you haven't really
nailed down the grammar
and and what i tended to do was i had
listened to simple stuff to begin with
and then i went to more difficult stuff
someone asked me on one of my youtube
videos uh is it worthwhile listening to
stuff you don't understand no
get stuff or you can access the text if
you can access the text the transcript
bring it into link as i did save the
words and phrases and that way you will
eventually be able to understand more
and more of it anyway that was cases the
second issue is
verbs of motion in russian there's one
the word to go in english i go i go
tomorrow i always go
not in russian aside from the fact that
the verbs have tenses and change for
tense and change for person okay
that's a minor problem bigger problem is
if you go
what they call multi-directional if you
kind of go
all the time or go and
come back that's one verb but if you are
going there that's another verb
and if you go
uh on a means of transportation that's
another verb and that also has its
multi-directional and unidirectional
form and that's just for goal and then
there's carry and come and fly and swim
very difficult to get a handle on and to
actually be able to reproduce it doesn't
prevent you from understanding the
language but it is very difficult to
nail it down when you're speaking
and then we have the aspect of verbs and
i should get i have read these
definitions so many times it's if the
action is completed or was supposed to
be completed or might have been
completed or was never going to be
completed then you use one form but if
in fact it was completed or might have
been completed and except for the other
exceptions then you use this other form
i don't understand it i've read them so
many times
and here again it's just exposure and
eventually because you can't be trying
to go through all these logical
explanations while you're speaking so
you to my mind you have to expose
yourself to a lot of the language and
then eventually start speaking a lot
okay i could get into other issues that
are different but they're minor like you
know the word for like in where okay
where but in russian is also uh you know
from where two are actually different
words those are minor issues the big
problems in russian are those three bug
bears cases
verbs of motion and aspects of verbs
now the good news
russian is fascinating it's a beautiful
language
the country is fascinating their culture
and history is fascinating the people
who appear kind of somewhat stoic in
fact are very warm
and uh they tend to speak their minds
and say what they think
and uh
don't worry too much about the details
but that's what makes them so uh
fun to be around and i would say too
that there is this in russia
you know there's no compromise
and and i think that's how they approach
uh even artistic creation or or sports
and that's why we see a lot of artistic
creation in russia outstanding
ballerinas outstanding musicians
or whatever scientists and even in sport
uh you know
certainly in hockey i find the russians
are just magicians they're artists
and so they have a tendency to uh really
commit themselves in one direction
they're not uh they're not fence sitters
so
with that i'm sorry that i ran for so
long i could speak forever on the
subject it's been a big part of my life
the last five years all the last seven
but the last two i was on more on czech
and romanian and portuguese and whatnot
uh it's been a big part of the last uh
you know since my 60th birthday and will
continue to be so and i very much
encourage you to learn russian despite
the difficulties thank you for listening